I'm feeling a little a most over right
now because this is the new Mac sent
candle and a lot of you guys have sent
me links to this ever since the first
time that it was announced I was in
shock when I opened up the box because
Roewe sent me this as a present and I
had absolutely no idea what was in it I
was running out the door the head to the
airport and I brought it with me so that
I can make this smell test video in the
hotel for you guys
partly in Washington DC gentles back
there she's eatin pretzel I sent them
away I said you got a slop crunch in so
we're gonna do a smell test of the new
Mack scented candle hand poured soy at
the bottom it says enjoy our
interpretation of the first aroma you
smell when opening your lap book iPhone
iMac hand poured in Charleston South
Carolina oh my gosh it smells so lovely
it says interpretation because ah this
definitely doesn't smell like a new Mac
I don't think at all but if it is an
interpretation and it smells very very
lovely so for those of you that have
never smelled a new Apple product before
it is very very um money mature what the
smell is it's like a
it smells like lavender ish I can't
figure out what this scent is it smells
like sort of a lavender lavender mint
maybe a lavender mint that's what I'm
gonna go with but a new Mac doesn't
necessarily smell like lavender and mint
but it is a very nice calming aroma when
you do first open up one of the new
Apple products so I feel like if it is
an interpretation in it for sure
definitely is a very nice calming scent
I'm not even sure this nut it smells
good take his wet pick away like let me
let me close my eyes and think about it
I don't know it smells like a hand
poured soy candle I don't know I don't
want to say lavender what does it smell
like I don't know I think lavender and
mint it's making my eyes real wide let's
see what other people are saying new Mac
candles review smell review it does new
max into candle smells nothing like a
new Mac it apparently smells like some
odd combination of mint peach basil
lavender is Mandarin and sage I smell
the basil do you really yes I do too I
definitely smell the basil basil I'm not
sure what Mandarin and sage smells like
well that's it thank you again to ro and
thank you guys for watching I am never
going to burn this it is going to sit on
my desk in perfect condition actually I
might burn it just once it because I'm
gonna have to but I don't want to burn
it in the hotel I will burn it when I
get home
and of course maybe I can do a recap
video of the burning I can burn it in
slo-mo it'll be just really great
quality clickbait content I'll see you
guys then bye Oh God so so God actually
president role my god what Jenna likes
to have it the TV on once you go to
sleep it causes
all issues with my roommate Wow it's
almost like time to like wake up Oh what
about the astronaut ice cream I'm dying
if I Tod pass through we're going to